les cherry on va faire un jeu qui
s'appelle toute première fois et je vous
le dis vous allez voir des anecdotes sur
les premières fois de nos chroniqueurs
elles vont toutes s'afficher dans
l'écran et vous allez devoir retrouver à
quelques chroniqueurs correspond chaque
anecdote je vais jouer avec vous parce
que même moi je les connais pas donc la
première fois je me suis mis du tabasco
et du poivre sur le sexe ça c'est
castaldi chine ont cessé sur la faute
comme ça pour ça non mais bah non mais
bon vous savez pourquoi il a fait ça non
il ya un tout petit piment les maux
bénins mais mon père est très stressé
j'ai appelé mon père je dis papa qu'est
ce que je dois prendre pour être très en
forme
vous avez quel âge j'avais 13 ans une
seconde alors c'était ma dernière fois
comme ami s'est appelé il m'a dit écoute
ce qui est très bon pour avoir bien la
pêche tu te fais un jus de tomate et tu
oublies pas de prendre de mètres du
tabasco et du poivre
sauf qu'il les a pas mis sauf quand le
dow jones maquette aulas là où c'était
extrêmement douloureux oui oui j'aime
vous qui êtes vegan annonce par contre
j'ai pas encore goûté mais c'est mon
héros s'il vous plaît on est castaldi
calmez-vous un salut c'est moi mais
normalement à part un père de famille
quand son fils à présent lui dû surtout
au fait tu veux qu'elle me toi un peu
c'est un peu jeune non 13 en raison de
la menace que sur le sexe et non et on
lui dit protège toi surtout merci merci
en tout cas mathieu doit manquer un très
bon début nuit